hey how you doing today folks today's
video will be my continuation of the
plot league breakdown and we are
currently on Episode five so we are
nearing the end of the season so I sort
of expect things to start really picking
up by now because we know Game of
Thrones tends to have its most
action-packed episodes right before the
finale so we should be seeing them start
to set up everything and put characters
in position for some sort of bad or
attack in this one and I will start this
video like I have done with my others I
will first read the entire episode then
I will go back to the beginning and
break each section down as I work my way
down so let's begin
episode 5 it says Sam leaves old town
for Winterfell with Gilly and the baby
joy reunites with Danny a Dragonstone
after apparently healing his greyscale
in old town at some point earlier in the
season
Jon receives a raven letting him know
that bran and Arya are at Winterfell
John Jorah and ginjury not sure how he
gets in the mix set sail to the wall
there looking to capture a white the
White Walkers mindless zombies in order
to prove to the other Lords of Westeros
and Dany they exist and to gain support
in fighting them Jorah Gendry and john
spotting on the set leaving Spain on a
boat this is probably the most
compelling evidence for the leaks
veracity as they are such an odd pairing
of characters to be mentioned so
specifically in the leaks Jaime and
Bronn secretly meet with Tyrion and
Davos Tyrion tries to persuade Jamie to
get Cersei to surrender to Danny but
Jaime ignores it okay so let's go back
to the beginning and start breaking this
stuff down says Sam leaves old town for
Winterfell with Gilly and the baby so to
me I think this only means one thing I
think it means that Sam has learned
everything that he sought out for so now
it's time to get back and show Jon Snow
exactly what he has learned and help him
prepare for the war against the White
Walkers and personally I never expected
Sam to stay at the Citadel for the
amount of time that it truly would take
someone to become a maester
although we know Sam loves books and he
loves to learn the history of the Seven
Kingdoms and he also loved maester aemon
who always treated Sam like family so
it's not a surprise that Sam would want
to follow in his footsteps after he died
and become the new maester of the Nights
Watch at Castle black but Sam does not
have the time to be at the Citadel for
years and years to do everything it
takes to become one everyone knows that
time is of the essence and Sam knows
firsthand about what everyone really
needs to focus on that being the war
against the night's king and I think
Sam's main motivation for going to the
Citadel was mentioned by him when he and
Gilly were traveling to old town Sam
said I want to become a maester to help
John when the time comes so we will be
safe so I think now that Sam has found
the books that he needed it's time to
leave and meet back up with John so they
can start putting this knowledge to use
and I think Sam figured out how to cure
greyscale which I will talk about
shortly but most importantly I think he
figured out the magic that is needed to
create Valyrian steel now only if Sam
could find someone that is a blacksmith
especially one that already knows how to
reforge Valyrian steel and I'll get back
to that a little bit later but I think
while Sam is at the Citadel him and Jon
will still be in communication sending
Ravens back and forth mostly about Sam's
discoveries and I think once Sam finds
the information he's looking for he's
going to notify John and tell John that
he also has hearts Bane and I think
that's when John is going to tell him to
come on back and I also think at some
point
Davos probably told John about Gendry
and who he truly is and that he is this
skilled blacksmith and that he did set
him free at Dragonstone and maybe
someone they could use in the future and
I think while John and Davos are at
Dragonstone meeting with Daenerys I
think that's when Jon's going to send
Davos to find his ginjury that he has
been talking about that way he could
introduce him to Sam and together they
can start making Valyrian steel swords
for the war that's to come and I think
in return John or Daenerys could
legitimize ginjury and allow him to take
control of storms end
because we know that Gendry while he was
living in King's Landing
he was the apprentice for the blacksmith
table Beaumont I think that's how you
pronounce his name who was a foreigner
from the free city of Carr and what is
that city known for it's known for its
skilled blacksmiths who have the
knowledge of how to reforge Valyrian
steel which is exactly why Taemin
Lannister used him to reforged Ned
Stark's sword ice which he used to
create widow's wail and Oathkeeper so
not only do I think Gendry learned how
to reforge Valyrian steel while working
under him but I think with the
information that Sam learned while at
the Citadel I think Sam now knows the
magic that is used to create Valyrian
steel so I think Kendra can possibly
take any type of Castleford steel and
create an endless amount of swords using
Sam's learned magic but I want to move
on and it says Jorah reunites with Dany
at Dragonstone apparently after healing
his greyscale so like I said in previous
videos if this does take place and Sam
probably meets Jorah and is told he is a
Mormont
son of Sam's former Lord Commander at
the Nights Watch and I think upon
learning this Sam will want to help him
I'm sure if Jorah tells him he needs
cured that way he can get back to
Daenerys Sam may want to help him
because of that - considering Sam was
very fond of maester aemon who was also
a Targaryen Sam may want to help out out
of respect for maester aemon as well and
it also says John receives a raven
letting him know that Brandon Arya are
at Winterfell
and according to Watchers on the walls
sources which have been extremely
accurate so far apparently a stark
reunion does take place next season with
Arya bran and Sansa and personally I
really hope Jon gets to reunite with his
family as well hopefully when he leaves
dragon stone to go on this expedition
north of the wall he stops at home first
to see his family and maybe even tell
them what he's doing and how dangerous
it is and hopefully or maybe by then
bran will have learned more about the
night's king and his powers and then he
can give John some advice for when he
goes on his mission
which leads me to the next part where it
says John Jorah and ginjury set sail to
the wall and they are looking to capture
the Wight in order to prove to the other
lords of westeros and Dany that they do
exist so they can gain support to fight
them in the war it says this is the most
compelling evidence for the leagues
because these three characters are such
an odd couple just to be mentioned so
specifically and now seeing them in the
photos together I think it must be true
but I'm wondering how the conversation
went down that put these three in
position to go out on a mission together
I'm thinking John wants to take Gendry
to meet Sam as well that way they can
start forging Valyrian steel
and maybe jour is there during this
conversation and says something to John
like you know Sam you know that's the
guy that cured my greyscale let me go
with you the least I can do is help you
with this considering he did save my
life and maybe Jory even says something
to Daenerys like this is something I
have to do I have shamed my family and
was exiled from Westeros by Ned Stark so
let me help his son which everyone does
still think John is Ned's son and then
in return John could say you know if you
do this with me I will forgive you of
your crimes and allow you to live freely
in Westeros I will also take you to
Lyanna Mormont who I have this close
relationship with now at this point and
when she learns that you have helped me
I will talk to her about you being
forgiven by all the Mormons and
hopefully the thought of you disgracing
the name is forgotten so let me know
what you think about that how you think
that goes down how John doar and ginjury
are the one setting sail together to go
north why do you think these three
specifically chose to go together and
the last part of episode 5 says Jaime
and Bronn secretly meet with Tyrion and
Davos Tyrion tries to persuade Jaime to
surrender to Danny but Jaime ignores it
and this is it seems likely Jaime is
still madly in love with Cersei so I
understand why he would do this but
personally I wish Jaime would wake up
and get the hell away from Cersei and I
know most of you hate Jaime and want him
dead but I actually like him as a
character and want to continue
see him on the show only I want to see
him fighting for the right side of
course and we have yet to see any photo
evidence that this scene takes place so
I'm not even sure that it happens but
looking at this photo with Tyrion and
dobbers together while they are getting
ginjury makes me think they could have
met Jamie and bran before they found
injury and I would like to see Tyrion
and Bronn have a scene together always
like that duo I actually like Tyrion and
Bronn better than Jaime and Bronn
together
but that's just my opinion and maybe
when Jaime is nearly killed by Daenerys
and her dragons hopefully then he
realizes he is fighting for a losing
cause and in a war that he cannot win so
tell me guys what you think about this
episode how do you see some of this
going down comment below and let me know
your thoughts on all this please thanks
for listening guys I'll see you next
time bye